I tend to look at things from an
evolutionary perspective and so I think
that I mean I think a lot of a lot of
the focus for probably the answers to
that question are largely focused on
stuff that's happened in the last
thousand years or this these sorts of
things I tend to think I look at things
from an evolutionary perspective so I
think that where we are our brains we
really have spent most of their time
evolving on the African savannah and a
very little time evolving in what we
think is sort of our present day through
how we view things so I think we're a
lot more base than then we think we are
like the world has evolved much more
quickly than our brains have and so and
I think we don't acknowledge that enough
and so well I'd like to start turn that
around so really i don't i don't think
that we are a bad people and i don't
think we're different Americans
Canadians Europeans like I don't I don't
think we're sort of that much different
and I think the way that we've gotten
here is really is absolutely
understandable there was a time when
natural resources went on and on likely
just there was an incredible amount so
we really didn't have to think that much
about being wasteful and that's that's
sort of where we where we've come from
in this last century and so we sort of i
think we in a way conceptually have sort
of worked our way around the globe you
know when we sit we set out one way and
there's like lots and lots of forests
and it's sort of well we're just sort of
realizing we're about to hit our come to
the end and we have to relook at how we
do things so i don't think we're bad
people we just we didn't look it was
hard to see that far in advance it's
hard to think that we would actually
through those resources and and so now
we just we're learning quickly that we
have to have a different approach